welcome to instant death before we begin
you have to accept these terms
I won't flip out I will not destroy my
computer and I will always remember
there is no checkpoint okay hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to instant death
now instant death touts itself is a very
difficult game I don't know about that
I'm not on a percent sure so we'll find
out what happens it's a first-person
rage game but I never trust anything
that's touted to be a difficult game
we're just gonna see exactly how tough
you can be and apparently that's not
very green colors alright safe alright
okay well fit pop pop pop pop okay easy
enough
enter the portal of the passive level
okay easy enough okay let's do this for
real Z this time level two orbs okay why
do I need orbs collect three orbs to win
the level it's like the world's hardest
game I see how you are okay well this
isn't so bad
I can dig it easy Z alright let's do
this bridge okay
whoo you you you pew yep
easy peasy Jana Rama oh this is so easy
oh this is the easiest thing I've ever
seen ah I tripped my massive balls over
that one all right I see what you do I
see how you do game ha ha ha
no that's fine all right yes easy peasy
lemon squeezy all right good good good
rotating cubes Hey what could be so bad
about that one what could be so bad
hey you get back down here let me up
here okay not so bad okay oh the first
person's gone whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
whoa hey whoa that was not fair why well
that's not good
[Music]
yeah oh come on oh I hate this okay
right there safe I see it okay right
there safe okay just walking along the
path whoa don't like that okay that's it
come on dick hole dick hole dill weed
hey pull the clothes on that one oh god
okay easy easy easy easy easy
I got this oh no please okay got it got
it got it got it got it
okay all right now so bad bridge part
two how did you start it with him
running away from me take it back here
please may i mother may i
you think you can mess with the likes of
me do you even know who I am my name is
Margo Bart no no no please nope come on
all right no whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa easy easy like it
tweren't nothing like it like it weren't
all right like it well doesn't help no
hey what the [ __ ] huh you're fast
why were you fast Jesus you no no no no
ah it's so fast
it's so fast it's so fast ooh why is it
so okay god I don't like you why are you
so fast yeah this is gonna be the the
episode of me making moose noises all
day long okay well you didn't come all
the way over here you sank approve no
[ __ ] come on oh come on come on I had
that okay we're fine everything's fine
no excuse me sorry pardon - mwah mwah
whoa car Dana Morrow top R didn't Wow
C sums I can't no come on
you're not even giving me a goddamn
chance new guard Spanish match
there's nach who bat nope what the [ __ ]
I did that again I did that again no ah
[ __ ] big hairy baba ganoush you're gonna
taste the oh I was gonna say something
along lines taste my victory or taste my
sweaty balls I don't know okay I don't
know how I'm alive but I'll take it
whoa I'll take it I'm gonna be a bag
chooser okay I made that finally oh god
moose mating calls all day long at least
please please don't shorn this [ __ ] off
my okay we're fine we're fine
easy-peasy
haha I hate that how can I talk can I
talk can I duck
whatever I don't oh okay well then oh
you piece of [ __ ] god [ __ ] damn it oh
I hate that all of that oh I don't know
how I am Alive but I will wait
you're part I made it
okay I made it hi boy I am sweating up a
storm here faster cubes faster cubes oh
okay well this ain't no [ __ ] like I
said you ain't no canoe I smelt that
deaf all right boy I am very afraid
okay I'll miss that entirely that's fine
that means I'll miss everything else
into our really okay okay I'm fine I'm
fine it's all good it's all good baby
spin what's spinning I don't see no spin
I don't see no spin I don't see no I
don't see no [ __ ] I don't see nothin
somebody touch em I spin GATS how in the
okay don't like you yeah yeah yeah yeah
what is that what is that oh okay so it
doesn't doesn't it doesn't reach it's
okay just got a good where am i safe
right here okay nuzzled up against the
bosom okay
okay okay I don't think the screaming is
helping but I like it okay oh whoa hey
whoa hey whoa okay ease oh god no no no
no first try baby oh [ __ ] god damn it
of course of course I do
of course I choke oh ah [ __ ] hell
it's Oh easy peasy
easy no easy peasy okay I got this all I
got to do is get across the pillars just
right like a like a virus
come no matter what
ah come on just jump jump jump you
bastard
all right spinny bastard the blender of
death it's all good I got it oh right on
my nards it's easy it's easy I got what
I need again come on come on Big Boy
show them what you're worth okay yes
please don't [ __ ] it up remember where
the orbs are I don't think I want that
why do I want to remember where the orbs
are why do I wanna lose okay oh I see
you norm
yay one one okay great God one
oh there's two okay give me a third ha
ha I found you last one okay I just got
to make it back now easy enough
why am i running oh there's no need to
run in the hallways okay
Oh God ah my brain ah my brain my brain
my iris no time for death laser I give
up
yeah I just see what the death laser is
I'm not gonna make oh do I need to
remember because oh ah I see okay it's
the same oh it's the same orb position
but now there's a death laser is what
you're saying okay all right well time
for death laser looks like I'm going to
be lasered to death
[ __ ] well yeah well laser is activated
well that's not good
okay where is it where's the laser
but oh okay that's the laser okay all
right
that one hurts my eyes I think I'm done
for now so that is instant death lives
up to his name very difficult very
difficult but not too bad it's pretty
good so anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of this game down in the
comments below I'll provide a link to
this game if you want to bash your head
against this proverbial wall so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know if you got other difficult games
that you want me to play and possibly
rage at so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]